hey
hi i'm chris fox lead gameplay designer
on plants vs zombies garden warfare and
i'm here with our creative director
justin weeb to talk about our newest
update legends of the long
a new game mode we'll be introducing
soon is called taco bandits taco bandits
is our take on sort of a classic capture
the flag but of course using cool tacos
as the thing to get you know crazy dave
has a fortified taco in every map and
the zombies are trying to get it so the
zombies need to capture three tacos from
the plants taco stands but the plants
know the zombies are coming so they have
fortified their area they've set up line
defenses they've got potted soil bags
you know lining the area they've got
lookout towers they can plant their
potted turrets for the first time in any
arena where they can now try to hold the
line against the zombie advance but the
zombies can now summon brown coats or
whatever ai they want from the grave
dirts so they can actually try to
overwhelm the plants with just sheer
numbers i think it's gonna it's gonna
leave a lasting impression on this is
what capture the flight could look like
you know it doesn't have to be just a
flag anymore
we have seven brand new characters for
legends of the lawn we'll start with the
zombie side we have the centurion who is
our roman inspired soldier variant he
has a single shot semi-automatic weapon
does fire damage on impact you know very
fast very accurate good at range
there's also the paleontologist
scientist which might be my favorite of
this new pack he's basically got like
the bones of a tyrannosaurus on him
mixed in with a little bit of
triceratops on his head he shoots molten
magma so whether you're at range or up
close he does fire damage which burns
over time it's unique for that class
there's the the sanitation expert he's a
stinky toxic based engineer he's
basically a decked out garbage man with
garbage strewn all over him and he's
going to be shooting some fairly toxic
garbage blasts at you from his trash can
launcher and finally on the zombie side
we have the golf star who is the
all-star variant he's almost like a
sniper he's the fastest rate of fire in
the game also has more zoom than a
standard all-star so we made him kind of
accurate at range and not so accurate
when you're not zooming
moving on to the plant side with the
chomp thing who is our kind of swamp
monster inspired chomper uh he's kind of
gross he shoots bugs and mud and dirt
and all that kind of fun stuff
his kind of trick though is that he
enters his health regeneration state
faster than any other chomper so if
you're taking a little bit of damage and
you can actually get away from the
battle you'll heal up much faster moving
along to my personal favorite of the new
characters it's the alien flower
this is very different for the sunfire
class she actually shoots kind of spores
that explode when they hit the ground
and they linger in the air for a couple
of seconds so you can kind of make
little traps where you're shooting the
ground and zombies are walking through
it and taking damage
finally on the planet side we have the
jade cactus and she's our slower moving
higher health cactus variant her weapon
sticks in the ground for a second and
then explodes so it's kind of a new
twist on how the cactus plays if you hit
players directly the damage happens
right away but if you hit the ground you
know you can kind of time it and wait
for people to run towards you
we know pvc fans love customizing their
plants and zombies and we've got more
stuff for you kind of the new thing here
is the concept of a set so we have uh
you know hats and glasses and facial
hair and stuff that's meant to go
together things like the farmer set and
the boogie or brains out set and we have
a skunk for the cactus all sorts of
crazy stuff
they look really great together but if
you want to mix and match and make your
own unique look that's really cool too
there's a ton of new customization in
this update so i encourage you to go
find it all one of my favorite
customization sets is for the peashooter
and it's it's mass effect and inspired
so it's very high tech and then kind of
clean looking it looks really good when
you put it on the uh the plasma piece
shooter so check that one out for sure
and we have some new consumables this
time around as well starting with the
plants we have the laser beam that you
may recognize from pvz2's far future
he shoots blue lasers out of his eyes so
he's pretty good from a medium to long
distance
we have the heel zombie who will try to
seek out injured zombies and top up
their health he's gonna be really
effective i think we also have the yeti
he'll run at you and explode and try to
freeze you the team had a ton of fun
making this pack you know between the
seven new characters the new game mode
and all the crazy new customization
we're really excited to see what the
players think so uh pick it up get your
hands on it and let us know what you
think
you